meantime back here at home 70 of our
nevada army guard soldiers assigned to
the delta company first squadron 221st
cavalry they're going to be headed to
kuwait here in just a few weeks as
kirsten joyce reports they will be there
for nine months
defend it with honor commitment and
professionalism this morning a special
recognition ceremony for what will be
the first overseas deployment for delta
company first squadron 221st cavalry i'm
actually very excited since the entire
squadron deployed to afghanistan in
support of operation enduring freedom
back in 2009
sergeant jocelyn villafain's role for
her first deployment a mechanic i just
feel really proud to be able to do this
a sentiment shared by her entire
squadron make sure that you know we
get good training opportunities and
good growth for all of our soldiers
company commander hayden lanao will be
in charge of direction and training as a
tank company we do a lot of gunnery
requirements
a lot of
both individual and all the way up to
platoon and company level training he's
been serving for 10 years and recognizes
the importance of staying connected to
family during a mission a big reason
family members sacrifice was also
recognized during today's ceremony we
couldn't do our job without their
support kirstjen joyce live local now
[Music]